umit il est étudiant en première année
de philosophie à tolbiac 19 ans il
habite chez son père à sevran
auto-entrepreneurs effet du tutorat en
collège et aide son père sur des
chantiers ça lui rapporte environ 200
euros par mois
need j'habite à se brancher mon père ce
serait mon rêve d'habiter plus près de
ma faculté mais c'est impossible
les loyers sont beaucoup trop chers je
suis devenu un poids pour mon père
électricien qui n'arrivent pas à boucler
ses fins de mois
ben écoute vous avez été manifesté
aujourd'hui absolument oui j'y suis allé
alors j'ai pas été dès la première heure
comme certains mais j'ai respecté le
rendez vous à 14h à garder là ça m'a
permis avant d'y aller de regarder un
peu la télévision entendre les propos du
député d'un député en marche sur bfm tv
qui qui en dehors
en dehors des invectives envers les
groupes politiques qui ont appelé à
manifester mais a réaffirmé encore que
le problème des manifestants était qu'il
n'avait pas compris que le gouvernement
manqué de pédagogie d'accord alors que
une rengaine qu'on connaît bien que
timide parce que c'est vrai que comme on
l'a dit il ya un instant et sert et
comment il allait beaucoup dit il ya un
problème mais aussi de deux dialogues
bien on a l'impression c'est vrai que
voilà il ya un problème de volaille
c'est qu'on n'arrive pas dialoguer on
n'arrive pas à comprendre en fait ce qui
est proposé pour la plupart des gens il
ya beaucoup de gens qui sont dans la rue
parce qu'ils comprennent voilà ils
n'arrivent pas à dialoguer nous on nous
écoute pas on ne nous entend pas alors
toi tu demandes un revenu étudiants à
hauteur de 800 900 euros par mois
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de ça vous
donne aux mille étudiante
oui je pense que ce serait formidable
c'est la marque d'une mémé alors moi je
vous dira qu'elle est je pense que
laurent ça y est c'est ce qui va vous
dire à quel jeu joue d'ailleurs mais là
alors un moment on va le trouver où tout
cet argent bayadh et répondre en payer
plus d'impôts moi je comprends bien mais
oui mon nom
on a en a seulement l'agent cela qu'ils
vont la jouer ta g et que les gens qui
veulent absolument toujours garder les
gens font pas de torture mais moi moi
moi je crois
c'est le premier fils on a vu qu'il ya
des étudiants qui sont dans des voies
qu'ils imposent des situations très très
très près qu'il n'en dépense est vrai
toujours quelque chose dans les autres
pays
josé souple et 1900 euros richard moi
qu'est ce que vous dites alors laurent
soyez de travail de 35 heures par
semaine
with vous voulez oui c'est un avion
heureusement moi oui dans des études
c'est ça ouais ouais ou quoi non mais
attends mais il faut en effet comment
mes attentes je vous écoute vous pouvez
aller travailler en fait des études et
la plaine ge comme il le faut est ce que
vous écoutez les agences nationales 900
euros par mois mais que c'est la finir
6e club prendra qui ont des eaux vous
écoutera lui à l'âge et il ya des gens
qui bossent durement mais 1000 euros par
mois galère ils ont pas de régimes
spéciaux n'en problème en pas d'avancer
un problème et galère ça c'est un coup à
boire qui tourne dans leur poste de télé
et qui se disent que vous allez être
payé 800 900 euros par mois pour faire
des essais leur temps à boire par un
faux comme furent interdits de réalisme
je rappelle essai du père noël vous êtes
à perdre les gens voudront pas de
prouver sa bonne foi